il fait moins sept degrés aujourd'hui en
montérégie
un détail plutôt anodin si ce n'était
pas du fait qu ici beaucoup de citoyens
sont des sinistrés ils n'ont pas encore
les moyens de se chauffer à l'entrée du
centre communautaire de
terrasse-vaudreuil les résidents se
racontent leurs histoires de guerre six
mois ont passé depuis les inondations du
printemps
c'est ce pénible mois d'attentes
d'exaspération et de bureaucratie sans
fin micheline goupil tient sur ses
genoux des mois de soucis de cauchemar
c'est la première fois en six mois
qu'elle et son mari rencontre un agent
du ministère en charge en ils sont à
bout de souffle
parce que les antidépresseurs
et de médicaments
en supplément à 67 ans faute de soutien
ils ont dû avoir recours à une marge de
crédit hypothécaire
ils n'ont reçu que 1500 $ du
gouvernement pour au moins trente mille
dollars de pertes
ne disait pas autre mais arrêtez de
parler à travers votre chapeau douleur
dans la grande pièce il ya autant
d'histoires de détresse qui lie à
d'agents du ministère respecte le
gouvernement est venu lundi le 6
novembre chez moi pour évaluer mais les
dégâts à moi et moi dit merci pour votre
patience
on a vraiment été les saignements
on essaie dépourvu et
sa maison est inhabitable
c'est comme si on s'était arrêté au
printemps elle vit à l'hôtel depuis six
mois avec sa mère de 87 ans elles
avaient toutes les souvenirs dans mon
père l'ailette un mot des photos j'étais
comme ça c'est ce qui leur elle était
tellement désemparés qui a calé ce qu'on
avait toute personne se déplace sa mère
est morte la semaine dernière
carole poirier convaincu que les
inondations l'ont emporté inconsolable
elle ne sait toujours pas où elle va pas
ce livre c'est humain parce que si tu
étais prête moi c'est notre osa question
et elle n'est pas la seule à rigaud 30
kilomètres plus loin les dossiers
traînent aussi malgré les saisons qui
passent cette année
quand nous avons traversé la pointe aux
sables en mai c'était en bateau et les
gens fuyant catastrophe
aujourd'hui derrière ces façades se
cachent des ravages monstre au moins 25
maisons seront démolies
les terrains seront récupérés par la
ville les petits paradis comme celui de
yolande quartier qui sera indemnisée
pour la maison mais cent mille dollars
ou dessous de la valeur marchande
j'ai pas eu le droit de réparer ma
maison je n'ai pas le droit de faire ça
je suis obligé de partir
difficile d'en bas les toute une vie de
souvenirs c'est ici qu'elle est née et
qu'elle voulait finir ses jours
mais elle n'en peut plus de se battre la
dernière étape a été demandé à ma mère à
chaque fois seul ça a été un plus pour
moi
elle a fait son deuil et quittera rigaud
pour de bon mais elle en veux beaucoup
au gouvernement il ya macheda et
diamants qui est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
et en plus ce que je déplore c'est les
premières vignes qui ont été faites
parlez-en à sa voisine charest le dos
elle nous a reçu dans sa chambre d'hôtel
qu'elle occupe depuis le mois de mai
avec son mari bernard monnet chien
d'hagrid elle n'en peut plus de se
sentir comme un simple numéro dans ce
système elle attend maintenant son
permis pour démolir avant l'hiver mais
il n'arrive pas elle n'en dors plus la
même question hante lisent le dieu qui
normand sauvé ils viennent d'apprendre
six mois plus tard l'ampleur de leurs
pertes
il paye casse marié de toutes qu'est ce
qu'on en avait combien ont soulevé
chanceux de toutes les choses qu'on
avait acquis fonds n'avait pays en
travaillant de nommer pillon de tout
rénover ou démolir ils seront perdants
quoi qu'il arrive je voulais pas partir
du contenu mais vu que veut que ce qui
est arrivé pour être à partir des
barrières à 20 ans montrent les
montagnes des coûts même à soissons
[Musique]
mais à 60 ans recommencer à zéro c'est
terrifiant
ils ont besoin dun ils ne savent plus où
la trouver
[Musique]
d'avoir et on sent la détresse mais
comment expliquer ce retard honnêtement
on n'était pas prêt et les mini squatté
à qui on a parlé cette semaine nous le
confirme on a reçu au total 6000
demandes d'indemnisation contre 1000 une
année de notation normal donc pas assez
de personnel et la façon de procéder
était pas la bonne les gens nous disent
que c'était comme les douze travaux
d'astérix appel à la ville pour un
permis en rambo gouvernement
gouvernement renvoie la ville donc c'est
seulement cet automne que le
gouvernement à corriger le tir pour que
tout ce monde-là de travail ensemble
ça donne ce que vous avez entendu de
l'exaspération et de la déprime
j'exagère pas quand je vous dis que
toutes les personnes qu'on a croisé sur
le terrain à l'exception de une
fréquente en ce moment un psychologue et
leur calvaire est loin d'être terminée
oui parce que des inondations il va y en
avoir de plus en plus vont être non
seulement plus fréquentes mais plus
grave aussi est en zone urbaine c'est ce
que tous les experts disaient
aujourd'hui en alberta lors d'une grande
conférence sur les inondations
donc faut changer nos programmes il faut
s'attaquer à un problème dont on ne
parle pas assez c'est celui de
l'assurance privée ni vous ni moi ni la
majorité des gens qui nous écoutent sont
assurés pour des inondations terrestre
le canada est le seul pays du g7 qui ne
pas négocier avec le privé de programme
national donc même une fois que les
chèques seront reçus je les sinistrés ça
va seulement couvrir une fraction des
pertes donc c'est assez triste
voilà merci tamara vous en prie